pour ce sujet j'ai décidé de me faire
tatouer le visage de ses douze anges
parti comptait [__] c'est quoi ça tout
ça par tirage à massy natation d'elle
après ma vidéo sur le tatouage je vous
avais donné rendez-vous dans deux mois
pour le détatouage et ben voilà et
aujourd'hui le moment est venu
c'est pas juste aujourd'hui je vais vous
expliquer ça on me le faire retirer
j'avais plusieurs options
la chirurgie par exemple est bon pour un
tatouage aussi gros ça faisait quand
même beaucoup de poids enlevés
oui
ainsi une panade a commercialisé depuis
peu qui promet monts et merveilles mais
bon on va attendre un petit peu avec ce
genre de produits histoire d'avoir un
peu de rouille non moi j'ai choisi de
taper dans le grand classique le laser
mais commençons par le début avant même
la première séance il a rendez vous avec
le médecin
aujourd'hui c'est un jour important
parce que j'ai rendez vous au centre de
lasers pour calais tous les détails de
mon des tatouages
normalement c'est ok mais j'ai quand
même la petite appréhension que le
médecin jette un oeil à mon tatouage et
me disent ah bah non il ne s'agit pas
pouvoir le retirer a voulu garder sa
tête une consultation assez classique au
cours de laquelle le médecin s'assure
que vous ne prenez pas des médicaments
photosensibilisants c'est-à-dire qui
entraîne une réaction de la peau en cas
d'exposition au soleil mais aussi en cas
d'exposition au laser se renseigne aussi
sur vos antécédents maladie et allergies
éventuelles
par exemple si vous êtes enceinte le
médecin préférable et le principe de
précaution et refusera de vous des
tatoués ensuite si le tatouage est situé
dans une zone où la peau est bronzé il
faudra attendre un peu parce que le
laser peut laisser des traces blanches
dans ces cas là et c'est parce qu'on
veut bien sûr les machines ont des
réglages adaptés aux peaux mates ou aux
peaux noires le médecin en profite pour
inspecter le tatouage vous dire que dans
mon cas il est un peu surpris il lui
permet d'assurer que la peau est saine
et aussi d'évaluer le nombre de séances
à prévoir tout ça dépend du type et de
la couleur de l'encré mais aussi sa
quantité et de la profondeur des treks
en ce qui me concerne on est parti sur
six séances
et vu que vous vous posez la question et
fait effectivement une information
éducation d'importance et temps 50 euros
la séance
mais selon le type de laser le centre le
médecin est un type de tatouage ça peut
aller de trois à quinze séances voire
plus pour 80 à 300 euros à chaque fois
voire plus et sa double pic
ok mais comment ça marche mais rassurez
moi je vais vous montrer ça tout de
suite aller alors
non non pas du tout mais non
mais non en réalité il existe plusieurs
types de laser en l'occurrence la c1
kyus week le laser fait rien d'autre que
de la lumière qui est amplifié et mis
sous la forme d'un faisceau composé de
photons c'est-à-dire de particules
composent la lumière il a plusieurs
particularités
le laser c'est unidirectionnelle c'est à
dire que le faisceau est très précis ce
qui lui permet de se concentrer sur un
point il est monochromatique c'est à
dire que ces rayonnements ont tous la
même longueur d'onde ou à peu près avec
le quiou switch on peut sélectionner
différentes longueurs d'onde sont
efficaces chacune sur des couleurs
précises
sachez par exemple que le jaune le vert
et le bleu turquoise et des couleurs qui
sont difficiles à faire partir et que le
noir juste méfiance parfois les angles
sont mélangés pour obtenir une couleur
et du coup l'une peut partir mais pas
l'autre
dorian armes à l'arrêt qu'un tatouage
toujours alors par précaution avant de
commencer on se protège les yeux vous
allez voir ça donne un swag assez
indéfinissable
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
donc là ce qui se passe c'est que la
machine projette des photos sur mon café
ça ou très grandes quantités d'énergie
sur un temps très court de l'ordre de la
nanoseconde
alors vous en doutez une aussi grande
quantité d'énergie même sur une
nanoseconde
ça pique en gros les zones qui sont
douloureuses à tatouer sont aussi
douloureuse à des tatoués mais en pire
et ça pique
on peut mettre une pommade anesthésiant
une à deux heures avant le rendez vous
il ya des gens chez qui il faut baisser
l'intensité donc l'efficacité du laser y
en a même qui sont obligés d'arrêter
avant la fin du traitement
quand même ballot un regard l'énergie
envoyée par le laser fait exploser leurs
rangs de multiples petites particules
et c'est là qu'interviennent des
cellules dont on avait déjà parlé dans
la vidéo sur le tatouage en plus les
cellules qui sont chargés de faire le
ménage dans le béarn qu'on appelle des
maquereautage elle n'arrive pas évacuer
les pigments de lancre parce qu'ils sont
trop fait pour elle
et ben voilà une fois l'anc exploser ces
fameux macrophages peuvent perdre leur
job
le ménage alors comme ça on a
l'impression que c'est mon tout est
parti en fait pas du tout cet aspect
blanchâtre revoit la surface et juste du
casque libéré sur le passage du laser et
dans quelques heures le motif original
il va refaire surface
attendez on fait quand même vachement
surface là non bon alors il paraît que
c'est normal parce que même si c'est
foutriquet de macrophages sont des
sacrés petit goût lui eh ben ils mangent
pas tout d'un coup c'est pour ça qu'il
faut y retourner mais qu'il faut
attendre deux mois le temps qu'ils
disaient après la séance il suffit de
respecter les consignes du médecin et de
refaire son pansement avec de la pommade
cicatrisante comme il voulut prescrits
au moment du lancement c'est assez
clairement le meilleur moment et il ne
faut pas exposer la zone au soleil
pendant deux mois
il ya des traces rune plus ou moins
persistante pourraient apparaître
voilà donc pour résumer se faire retirer
un tatouage c'est beaucoup plus long et
beaucoup plus douloureux que se faire
tatouer est aussi beaucoup plus cher et
le résultat n'est pas garanti à 100%
alors évidemment et pas moi qui vais
vous faire la morale ni vous dire ce que
vous avez à faire mais au moins
maintenant vous avez les cartes en main
pour décider ensuite vous l'avez compris
je suis parti pour un an de traitement
donc il va falloir attendre un petit peu
pour juger de l'efficacité du traitement
parce que oui il ya toujours le risque
que tous ne partagent pas et je ne cache
pas que suite à tron c'est bon au pire
on peut recouvrir des traces avec un
nouveau tatouage
promis vous montrerai régulièrement
l'évolution du chantier
en attendant on se retrouve très bientôt
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là
d'habitude
mettez vous bien également et vous bien
[Musique]